[موسيقى]
لحظات عصيبه عاشها وليد داء الشهيدين
الشقيقين ظافر وجواد الريماوي بعد ان
خطفهما رصاص الاحتلال الاسرائيلي من بين
احضانهما
[تصفيق]
غضب وحزن في رام الله والخليل الشهيدان
ظافر وجواده استشهد خلال مواجهات وقعت في
قريه كفر عين المجاوره بقريتهما بيت ريما
شماليه رام الله
وفي بلده بيت امر في الخليل شيع الشهيد
الشاب مفيد الذي اصيب برصاص الاحتلال
بينما كان يوثقوا عمليه اقتحام اسرائيلي
للبلده
اصابه قوات الاحتلال الشاب جواد باصابه في
ايقاتله في جسمه واراد شقيقه الاخر الذي
كان بجانبه ان ينقله
بالصراخ واراد ان ينقذه بسيئه الاسعاف
يعني السكان المجاورين سمع- سمعوا صراخ
وهو ينادي اسعاف واراد ان ينقذه الطلبه من
منه لكي يمكنه ولكن قوه الاحتلال لم تعطيه
المجال
ياتي هذا التصعيد الاسرائيلي منظرا
بالمزيد من التدخل الامني مع اركان
الحكومه الاسرائيليه يراها فلسطينيون على
انها اكثر وتطرفا
يبدو ان الحكومه الاسرائيليه تخطط لتصعيد
كما يبدو تصعيد في القوانين تصعيد في
الاجراءات وتصعيد في الفعل على الارض هذا
الوضع ربما يستلزم فلسطينيا الذهاب اكثر
واكثر الى معاقبه اسرائيل لمعاقبه اسرائيل
في همم المحاكم الدوليه
جامعه بيرزيت اعلنت الحداده على ارواح
الشهداء خصوصا شهيديها الرماوي وسط حاله
واسعه من التمديد بين جمهورها كما حملت
الرئاسه الفلسطينيه وحقتها الى جانب
الفصائل الوطنيه والاسلاميه الاحتلال
المسؤوليه عند داعيت هذا التصعيد
باستشهاد اربعه شبان اخرين ارتفع عدد
الشهداء الفلسطينيه في الضفه الغربيه
وقطاع غزه منذ بدايه هذا العام الى 206
وهو ما يعتبره الفلسطينيون العام الاكثر
دمويه مقرره بالعامين الماضيين مشاعر
الحزن والغضب شعبيه وسياسيا في هذا اليوم
العالمي للتضامن مع الشعب الفلسطيني
ترافقت مع المطالبه بتدخل دولي عاجل
لمحاسبه الجنى
سمير ابو شماله الجزيره رام الله فلسطين